I emailed you recently by the sound of labs when lipids went up.
The biggest dietary change, for me, was going on a ketogenic diet, but not meat heavy,
only four to six ounces of clean beef, lamb, or chicken.
Heavy advance and leaping grades, and maybe that's why lipids went up.
The practitioner suspects allulose sweetener, not metabolized.
She says it's probably fruggedose, and that still messes me up.
Your thoughts on allulose?
So allulose is a sugar substitute that is a sugar alcohol.
Now, the benefit of sugar alcohol, it's thought that sugar alcohols don't increase
your glucose levels, and it's been proven that they don't increase most people's glucose
levels.
But some people do have a sensitivity to sugar alcohols and it can mess them up, so that
can be an issue, just like fruggedose.
Fruggedose is a common issue.
Some people have an issue with fruggedose, and it can spike their glucose levels.
Weird.
They can eat, you know, can eat berries, and they don't have a giant spike in glucose.
Some people can have a glass of carrot juice, and it doesn't spike their glucose.
I have a lung gal who, she drank a half a glass of carrot juice, and they're in glucose.
It would be way over 200, and she would just go get the shakes and all sorts of things.
She just had an issue with her ability to metabolize fruggedose and glucose from vegetables like
that.
So some people can have issues like that, that is outside of the spectrum of what would
be considered the majority of people, so just be aware of that.
The other thing she thought could be a factor is glyphosate.
She would like to test for it, says it affects sulfuration, cholesterol, all sulfate, all
sulfates, redox enzymes, oxygen-mide and deuterium metabolism, et cetera, or you think that increase
in consuming clean meat could be driving up lipids, numbers that much over four months.
I don't think it's increased in the meats, I think it's increased in the fats that could
be driving up your lipids, but I do think all these other things have an effect too.
So if my cholesterol goes up, is it because I'm eating more cholesterol?
Well, usually it's not, but if I'm eating a poor diet, or if I'm eating a lot of fats
that I'm having that could clog up my liver, that could increase my cholesterol.
So there's other things like your practitioner mentioned, that clog up your liver, the most
common, is pesticides and herbicides and glyphosates fall into that category.
Now, getting a glyphosate chest done is pretty simple.
So we have that from mosaic labs, they have a glyphosate chest, it's a nice little test.
And quite honestly, you know, we have run a lot of glyphosate tests said I have yet to
see somebody come back with a normal limit of glyphosates.
So it's really, really common, and I think it's even more common than people with our
cancer diagnosis.
So yeah, your cholesterol is up, your LDL, C is up, your HTL is stayed the same, which
you want that to rise.
It's not really rising that much.
Your triglycerides are up, and that's really a side of inflammation and eating a lot more
fats can be inflammatory.
The other thing you want to look at, too, is your ability to break down fats.
You want to look at your bile salts and the health of your gallbladder.
So more questions really to ask like, how are you, how do you feel like you're digesting
your fats?
Do you feel like you have to burp a lot after you eat a fat, eat more fatty foods, how your
bowel movements change, do you have stomach aches because of that?
What is your HTL balance in your gut to be able to break down the proteins that you're
eating?
Look at the blog I wrote about HTL and just alkalizing or acidifying your gut.
So if that's really important to follow, there's nothing wrong with getting a glyphosate
test done, though again, this is my experience, probably going to be elevated.